the jurogan experience so in the
beginning like when i first met you uh
today rather when i ran into you
first thing i said i was like are you
still on cloud nine like what is this
like
like you you you know
it was matt sarah and gsp that was like
the biggest upset ever in the history
sport right but this is like i think
this is there or bigger it might be
bigger
yeah i mean i that wasn't my era i'm in
the new generation this is my era so of
course to me it's the biggest but it was
huge because amanda was terrifying like
everybody was scared of her and you were
the one that wasn't scared of her yeah
no you can't be you're fighting like i
know but it's still it's like it's the
way you did it yeah was so wild like
while it was that like
dc's are you laughing because you were
counting me out the whole time no i'm
laughing because dc sent me a text and
in the video
you're very
very
dc sent me a text and uh it was a video
of me and him doing commentary in your
fight he goes bro he goes listen to us
we're just making weird noises
cause during the fight like
he's screaming like a little girl it was
wild yeah it was [ __ ] wild you know
when you were standing toe-to-toe with
her and smashing her with a jab in the
middle of the octagon we were like
gripping each other we were like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
it you can't describe
what that's like to watch because it's
like you can't it's hard to believe that
it's happening i felt like if you had a
chance to beat her it would be in a
scramble you would catch her and submit
her
grappling exchange wear her down and
submit her yeah but to see you standing
in the middle of octagon and smashing
her with a jab it was like ah
it was it was crazy it was so wild to
see it was almost like
the world changed yeah like the whole
world changed like what is not possible
is now possible yes well there's there's
two things first is um there's styles
we've already talked about that styles
makes fights but i knew stylistically
that i have the perfect uh style of
fighting to beat her and because there's
for example i'm not the type to run
around the ring the whole time and do
the point sparring thing and go to
decision it's like one of us is coming
out of here and that's it that's just
the way that my fighting style is i'm
the type where it's like if there's a
big puncher the only way to meet that is
meet fire with fire and i have to stand
in the pocket so i'm not the type of
person to run away in the fight i'm the
type of person to meet that fire head on
right and match it with my own fire and
i knew that that was how i was going to
win and so that's pretty much all i did
is just game plan that specific type of
you're gonna be in the pocket you're
going to have to meet this fire and you
absolutely cannot shy away from it well
you said it leading up to the fight that
you're gonna drown her
yeah
i mean i've been calling for this fight
for five years everyone's like this
girl's talking all this crap you know
she's this and she's that and getting
upset at me like but i've been calling
for this fight since i won uh katzengano
at ufc 200. she beat misha that night i
beat cat cat had just recently beat her
and in the press conference amanda's
saying
uh that i'm next and then rhonda got to
cut the line and you know rhonda had
just gotten knocked out by holly holm
and instead of her you know having to
fight somebody else she got an immediate
title shot and she got to cut the line
and i was like that was my fight she's
the champ said that i was next and so
rhonda came in she got knocked out and
then i
you know i got put to the back of the
line again but i was constantly saying
even when ronda was champ and i won the
ultimate fighter i kept saying i want to
fight ronda i want to fight rhonda and
they wouldn't they wouldn't give me that
fight but the fact that she knocked out
rhonda helped your fight it really did
when you finally got her yeah because
she's a legend by then true because
before then she was
super dangerous everybody was
very aware that amanda was like super
[ __ ] dangerous and a vicious knockout
artist but
beaning rhonda the way she did put her
on the world map right when she knocked
her out in 48 seconds everybody's like
holy [ __ ] right you know and
your
your fight with her was bigger because
of all the delays like it because she
achieved this
goat status six years i think she's been
unbeaten just knocking knocking people
out for like the last six years so the
fact that she knocked out cyborg like
that too incredible right and then you
just stood right in the [ __ ] pocket
yeah
i know and that's great is if i can get
people emotionally invested in me
whether it's in my successes or in my
losses whatever it is as long as you're
watching and as long as you're you know
gripping your seat at the end of your
seat and freaking out i want to invoke
that emotion in people and that's why i
love fighting i think is because you
know whether you're invested in the loss
or the success you're you're watching
and you're like feeling some type of way
and your heart's you know going through
your throat and and to get that reaction
from people and to see the you know
um outpour of people reaching out to me
and how i made them feel it was like it
almost made me feel guilty in a sense
i'm like really yeah my dad lost 15
pounds like this guy's throwing up you
know people are like putting you know
this guy's like putting um you know
pissed off that they lost all this money
you know and then there's people that
are like super happy but like the
emotions of like people close to me is
seeing how
much i put them through i'm like i'm
sorry i did that to you guys you know
like it makes me feel bad you know i'm
like oh man i'm really putting these
people through the ringer like i feel i
feel guilty you know that's hilarious
listen they're all invested now you know
after that fight everybody's invested
yeah that was one of the best fights
i've ever seen thank you in terms of
like
like what do you want out of a fight you
want to you you want to be completely
immersed in the world goes away all
you're thinking about is what's
happening right in front of you and
because of your effort because of what
you accomplished that night you change
the way people think about what's
possible and not possible that's
everything we want from a fight
everything you were the underdog you
came in
you were counted out by so many people
you fought the greatest of all time and
you [ __ ] her up yeah and the way you
did it like the whole world everybody
that watched that was like holy [ __ ] the
world is a different place now yeah it
just goes to show you how strong the
mind is and how you know it's gonna
sound corny but my mom always used to
tell me you can do anything you set your
mind to what is next do you think a
rematch is next absolutely yeah there's
still naysayers out there there's still
people that think it was a fluke there's
still people that are harassing me
there's still people that are like being
like she's gonna kill you you know
they're like 10 seconds and you're dead
you know and so i i just i would love
nothing more than to to put the
naysayers to bed for one last time oh
yeah yeah now have you guys started
discussing when and if that can happen
yes um and you know in my mind in a
perfect world july 4th yeah july 4th
yeah yes yes
yes yes i totally would love to find
vegas biggest card um in my mind uh i
would always want i've always wanted to
anyway since i was on the ultimate
fighter i would love to coach the
ultimate fighter i just you know the
last time that we were supposed to coach
before this fight she she decided not to
do it and and so i'm just trying to coax
her into doing it you know like come on
let's go she ultimate fighter and then
we'll fight in july it'll be perfect
that would be great yeah so that in a
perfect world that's how it would be for
me but i would anticipate sometime in
the summer for the rematch the ultimate
fighter what kind of a commitment is
that it's like a six-week commitment
yes
something like that i it's it is like a
six-week commitment so you just live in
vegas for six weeks bring your kid yep
training there and then coach people
yeah now um that has always like
traditionally been a way that people
have been able to like get rivalries
really cooking because when you're next
to each other all the time for six weeks
it just bubbles up yeah what do you
think that's going to be like being
around her for six weeks you know it's
not a personal thing it's not like i
have anything against her personally i
think that she's great you know um
and if i were to be on the show i can
pretty much guarantee you i'm not gonna
be pulling any shenanigans
if she pulled the shenanigans then it's
on you know what i mean but like i'm not
out to you know be vicious or malicious
or anything like that um but again like
i said like if i get pushed in that
direction that's a different story but
yeah it's i've seen pat like i think the
conor mcgregor one where he was like
poking at uriah is just hilarious epic
like well how about when ronda was on
with misha and she beat her in a
competition just to the fingers like so
angry oh yeah
and i was right there next to her when
they were at the red rock and misha's
like she's like you can't even throw
punches and ron is like she stormed off
so angry she went and got edmond and
they came back and like i thought they
were going to throw down right then and
there literally like it was it was
awkward well you get to see
sides of people's personality when you
have to see them on these exchanges with
each other right remember rashad evans
and rampage yes and like you're a [ __ ]
treat me like a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
treat me like a [ __ ] like like face to
face with each other for like
several seconds yes saying that yeah or
even like van der ley and and she'll
sign oh that's a classic yeah they
straight up spot yeah that's a classic i
i i would hope like you know that that
wouldn't be the case you know like let's
be adults about this but then that's the
flip side it's like we're trying to sell
the fight right we're trying to make
people invested and make sure that they
watch the fight so it's like how can it
be you know this epic season of the
ultimate fighter without that kind of
chaos but it's like amanda's not that
kind of person and i'm not either yeah i
don't think it has to be that way the
fight is gonna be giant no matter what
right when you guys have a rematch holy
[ __ ] god it better be in north america
the other thing that was interesting
about that fight was her last two fights
before that megan anderson and cyborg
what was it megan anderson inside but
were they back to back
i think so in the 45 division yeah yeah
so both of our fights were at 45. like
she hadn't defended 35 in quite a while
two years yeah so
the making that extra 10 pounds is
probably a big deal like she looked very
lean at the weigh-ins like leaner than
you ever see her before lean and she
showed up all half-naked and she was
ready to go she was in the best shape of
her life it looked like she looked
ripped she looks yeah she looked ripped
but you know oftentimes when people
haven't cut weight yeah and then they
have to yeah you know that you see like
uh there's a difference in like way your
body bounces back from that yeah well
her focus in her camp was two fights i
gotta make weight and then i gotta worry
about juliana
my focus was all i have to do is worry
about amanda that's it
that was my only fight that was my sole
focus her sole focus is i got to be
miserable for the next three months
because i got to make weight and make
sure that i'm you know up to par and me
i've been grinding the whole time so i
was like all i got to focus on is just
her and everybody was aware of the kayla
fight everybody was aware that kayla was
in the audience yeah they were trying to
set that fight up and how dare they
right because kayla is like talking
about how she's training partners with
amanda and how she learns so much from
amanda and how amazing amanda is as a
training partner and how um you know she
has just learned so much from the champ
and so i'm so confused because you want
amanda to win so that you can fight your
friend
well they just want to get paid yeah
well she's getting paid she's getting
paid more than i am at the uh making the
millions over there at the pfl i think
the idea was that and i'm just guessing
that amanda
you know when this
worldwide recognition is the greatest
women fighter of all time and then you
get if she beat you then you get this
giant super fight with this olympic judo
medalist who seems like you know when
you look at kayla she seems like a
threat like you go okay well amanda's
just like super strong
like really good grappler knockout
puncher
kayla
is such an
elite judoka she's so good and she's so
[ __ ] strong
you you they go like that could be a
giant super fight yeah and i think they
probably thought if she came over to the
ufc they would have like the biggest
female fight of all time yeah well i
really mess that up
who needs friends with who needs enemies
with friends like these you know
especially with kayla and amanda being
like training partners and like hugging
each other and and now they're gonna
fight each other like come on it looks
ridiculous but if kayla wants to come
over to the ufc and make weight let's
let's pack your lunch
35 45 whatever you guys want to do you
fight her at 45
yeah i mean all i can say like we
already established if it don't make
money it don't make sense and what's the
job of a fighter especially with the
window being this small and your
opportunity being this small i gotta
jump through a window this little yeah
my job is to make as much money as
possible right so pay me i'll fight
whoever you all fight fedor
pay me
just pay me i hear you you know i feel
like i'm not asking for too much
especially now that i'm a champion i've
been saving my silver bullets this
entire time and now that i got it it's
like i want to get is that too much to
ask i mean as a professional yeah don't
you feel like you should of course
there's flip side no one's holding a gun
up to your head no one's making you
fight no but i'm a professional yeah you
know and i'm at the
height of my game i'm the champion i'm
at the top of my league you know pay me
also you have a child you have a future
you know you have a window of
opportunity with fighting that doesn't
last very long i mean it's one of the
smallest windows of opportunity for an
elite professional athlete i gotta hold
on to this little chunk of money that i
have for the rest of my life you know
it's like what do you i feel like i'm
not asking for too much you know what i
mean i just want what's fair
i think if you beat amanda again at 45
excuse me
when yes at 35 and then you fight her
for the 45 pound title yes that would be
crazy that would be like bullying yeah
well somebody suggested well what if she
uh doesn't decide to take the fight with
you and decides to take an easier fight
at 45 and retires off into the sunset
like she can't she can't do that she
would look like the biggest coward on
earth
sometimes people just get worn out by
the pressure too though that's a that's
a factor
how hard is it to go do your road work
when you're waking up in silk pajamas
every morning it's marvin hagler you
know he's another guy who walked away in
his prime yeah good for marvin good for
marvin but i mean it's got to be
difficult you're sitting on 10 mil in
the bank it's
motivation is just not there